I always try to figure out you know what
makes certain brands really stand out
and probably more importantly than just
stand out what makes them stand the test
of time what actually makes them
something where people you know not only
next year but the next 20 years find
important relevant and meaningful in
their lives
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of fam Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking about iconic
advantages meet soon you best-selling
author of iconic advantage and friction
soon he was a best-selling author and
expert on Innovation and design his
latest book friction asks businesses to
consider adding more friction for their
customers and employees to create
greater engagement meaning belonging
report Assurance competence and
exclusivity he most recently served as
the global vice president of innovation
and officer at VF Corporation the parent
organization to over 30 Global apparel
companies including the North Face Vance
Timberland Nautica and Wrangler before
this he worked as a general manager at
the Clorox company and Chiquita Brands
as a consultant and domain and Company
and is a Founder for numerous
venture-backed startups
talking about you know your journey or
career a brand creation differentiation
and all that fun stuff so so we'll have
a great conversation over these 20
minutes
um you have such an interesting uh
background
um coming from a you know an electrical
engineering initially Stanford Business
School you're an Adjunct professor at
Parsons School of Design today is
speaker and consultant uh so you know
what what sort of been your guide
throughout throughout your career you're
making transitions engineering brand
identity what's that been like for you
yeah I've always had I would guess you I
would consider myself a brand nerd I've
always been interested in the idea that
you know humans have relationships with
uh different brands uh there are some
Brands we fall in love with uh and if we
fall in love with them I think it's
really contingent on those of us who
have uh the responsibility to Steward
those Brands to make sure we don't give
any reason for folks to fall out of love
with the brands right never give them a
reason to be even on the fence with the
brands and and even when I was in high
school I I had this curiosity about
Brands and products and the
relationships that I actually have with
humans and so as an engineer I came at
it from really how do you design and
build them but I was also very
interested in the idea that it went
beyond the actual physical product to a
relationship and so I think for most of
my career I've been
um I think going from this idea of
understanding how to make the products
but then once the product services are
created what's the relationships that
are created
by the interactions and by the
experiences and so I think most of my
journey has been around trying to
basically unpack that understand that
write a little bit about that talk about
that and continuously meet new people
like yourself and in meeting people like
yourself I always learn something new
and so that's what makes it fun and
exciting so tell me a little bit about
product and brand creation what what
what what is the complexity around that
that really made you curious or
something that's that's worth
investigating further
sure you know actually one of the most
uh areas that had the highest curiosity
was around apparel and fashion you know
it's interesting that
um a product such as a shirt right and
depending on the color of the shirt how
it's cut
um the design of it the style it can
make the same person feel differently
about themselves
um depending on if they were wearing a
different color or if they're wearing a
different style shirt and that was
always something that drove my curiosity
um this idea of fashion and design and
um and how that would impact the idea of
how brands are created in people's minds
and so yeah I was always interested in
what creates this idea that
um you know depending if you're driving
a I don't know let's say let's drive
your Honda versus you're driving a same
car same size but it happens just to
have a Porsche symbol on it right and
and it has a 911 oven on it you feel
very differently about maybe even
yourself as you drive it about the
product and even how people you you
think even how people perceive you when
you're actually using two different
products so yeah I always try to figure
out you know what makes certain brands
really stand out and probably more
importantly than just stand out what
makes them stand the test of time what
actually makes them something where
people you know not only next year but
the next 20 years find important
relevant and meaningful in their lives
and so my first book actually iconic
Advantage was really looking at how how
Brands really stood the test of time and
not only stood the test of time stood
for something different and meaningful
that made them become the standard
Bearer for whatever that call it
meaningful distinction was and with
longevity
become iconic for that point of
Distinction so yeah I was always very
curious about how Brands did that and
how products did that and how Services
did that and so yeah that's sort of the
journey that I've been on
and so if we're looking at the challenge
of creating a standard right you
mentioned that is a part of the strength
of of brand creation which speaks to
longevity it speaks to really defining a
leadership within a category what is it
what does it really take to become a
standard and and ultimately what
differentiates a good brand someone that
manages to sort of win this game and and
reach that standardization Point yeah
that's a great question you know so we
looked at 50 different companies that
had portfolios of iconic products and
services and they and by having those
iconic product Services they became
iconic Brands them and themselves and we
found three distinguishing qualities
that all of them shared and the first
one you kind of mentioned it it's this
idea of Distinction there's something
that makes them Stand Out versus the
competition something that if you and I
were to talk about that brand we would
give them credit for something that they
would actually uniquely own
um and so that was sort of the First
Quality that we saw is that most all of
them had this idea of uh distinction and
differentiation
uh the second one was very important and
it wasn't that they weren't just
different for a different sake it was
whatever they were distinctive for was
highly relevant and meaningful to the
audience that they wanted to become
iconic too and what was important about
this idea of relevance wasn't that it
wasn't just the point in time it wasn't
just yesterday it was this idea that
they were going to be relevant yesterday
today and tomorrow they had this ability
to have sort of this Timeless relevance
and then lastly Within
the audience they wanted to be iconic
for they were universally recognized for
that distinctive relevance and that's
what allowed them to really become
iconic
if we're looking now from from the
get-go
you know what try to piece together from
an entrepreneurial perspective you're
building a brand and how intentional do
you need to be and at What stages as
you're trying to build an iconic brand
in other words where where does strategy
play into your intentionality or the
actions you need to take in order to
become an iconic brand is this something
that you need to build from the get-go
is this something that you need to that
eventually you start thinking about as
you see that you're getting traction how
early on do you need to be you know
cognizant of this
yeah you know I work with a lot of
startups and most of them say look you
know I'm just trying to survive I'm
trying to get to the next round of
funding I I'm just trying to build my
MVP and I I fully appreciate that and
obviously you have to sequence your
priorities and if the sequences I need
to just you know build a minimal viable
product then do that but once you've
gotten a certain amount of traction once
you actually have customers then I do
think the intentional strategy of
thinking about how do I create something
that goes beyond
the
the best technology or the fastest or
the largest you know I always tell
startups that I work with
that it's not the biggest or the fastest
or the most bells and whistles
um or most technologically uh uh uh
gifted mousetrap that gets the mice it's
the one with the stinkiest cheese so
even from the get-go I asked Brands to
think about what's your stinky cheese
what makes you I guess smell more
fragrant you know to attract mice
where you don't have to have the best
mouse trap and so if you can create
stinky cheese which oftentimes is a
point of Distinction that you have a
great story that's very relevant to your
audience and your storytelling around
that allows you to create that fragrance
so I always talk about it with startups
don't just worry about trying to be the
biggest or the fastest or the most bells
and whistles really think about how do
you actually stand out in terms of how
you talk about it and how you share and
how people actually experience it so and
what's been this is what's been a
differentiating factor for in the
storytelling side of things and the
stinkiness and what what's what's been
separating the good from the excellent
sure so a couple pieces of advice about
that I find that a lot of startups and a
lot of new businesses try to be
everything to everybody okay and what I
hate I think what happens with that is
it there's a lot of dilution right you
try to create a point of Distinction and
you try to make it differentiated with
as big of audience as possible and in
reality you don't have the marketing
muscle you don't have the presence you
don't have the testimonials to really
own everything with everybody what I
always recommend is have one thing that
really makes you unique versus your
competition make it your signature and
own it with four people literally with
four people do it really well with those
four or five people and guess what they
will then become testimonials for you
they'll become converts and evangelists
and be able to talk about whatever that
point of Distinction is that you do so
well with those four people or five
people that then it becomes and builds a
Groundswell but I I think the the
biggest trap is when everyone says look
either I've got to be different for
different sake or I want to be
everything to everybody and I don't
think that really works well I think
it's much more important to be some have
a thousand people that love you versus
having a million people that know you
um right and so if you're if for
companies that are looking at a blue
ocean and they're trying to to say okay
I have there's this there's this blue
ocean here that I want to become
potentially a market leader in because I
have a thesis on on some problem space
and and some Innovative approach that I
can bring to an emerging problem and I
realize that there's a potential to
become a market leader how do you
balance between sort of the the smaller
distinction okay these are the 10 people
that I'm gonna make them love me
how and how do you compensate for that
within a larger strategy for how do I
become in two three years somebody that
not only these 10 people love but also
these other thousand people who have
different needs and wants they also love
so how do you balance a long-term
strategy for Market leadership versus
sort of the shorter term strategy of of
making these specific people love you
consider a normal question that most
Business Leaders reach when they get to
a certain scale and so you're asking to
vary what I call
um common sense question you know like
how do you balance that I actually think
it's misleading in that I'll take an
example I I used to work at VF Corp
which is a large apparel company and it
owns 30 different brands but one of the
brands it owns is a very important brand
The North Face right it's a it's a
leader in its category in terms of
outdoor wear
and this was maybe 15 years ago
we were looking at the market and at
that point we thought oh maybe you know
we we need to appeal to more people
and what we learned in all our work in
all our analysis is that if we lose our
focus on the call the two or three
percent that are you know climbing Mount
Everest that are always climbing the
Seven Peaks and and and and always
trying to uh we call them you know the
the the the the hardcore explorers right
um if we lose our focus on those folks
then everything else we did throughout
the entire product line
um was diluted and if anything we
decided that we're going to double down
on making sure that no matter what we
did we always service those one or two
percent that we're going to be climbing
Mount Everest if you knew
that the Sherpas and everyone that's
going to Everest used primarily The
North Face sleeping bags and jackets and
all the equipment right then guess what
it Halos everything else you're doing so
I think the same point applies to your
question which is you know by actually
making
call it that that one percent extremely
happy okay and maybe over indexing in
terms of delivering satisfaction and
product functionality and Innovation to
them it Halos the other 99 because they
end up serving as sort of a torture test
and probably the best evangelists and
testimonials you're gonna get for the
you know for from the other 99 of the
people which quite frankly don't matter
as much and so that's why I say man nail
that one percent nail it and continually
nail it meaning that you should have an
innovation pipeline that every year is
bringing new innovation new story new
design to that one percent that Delights
them and they will talk about it and it
will Halo to the other 99 percent
love it love it where is your personal
passion and excitement for
for brand creation and iconic Brands
where's that coming from these days
um well I I think it started off early
as a child you know I I always loved um
products I loved uh and then you know
obviously we were much more product on
me when I was young and and now it's
much more of a service economy and I I
think you know where is it coming from
today is the same place that it came
from when I was a kid it it comes from
this idea that you know
um I've always been a nerd about the
idea of relationships and and so
um I have some brands that I've fallen
in love with all my whole life and I
don't want to ever have a reason not to
have a relationship with those Brands
and so I work with a lot of companies
that uh I really have a great respect
for the brand that they've created and
for some reason they've fallen off on
the Wayside and I'm like that's not I
don't want to have a reason not to have
a relationship with this brand in the
next five to ten years
um and so that's the motivation is that
you know like your best friends right
you don't want to lose your best friends
all right and I feel the same way about
the brands that I have strong
relationships with is I don't want to
feel like I have to swap out a new best
friend every two years I don't think
it's exhausting and I don't think it's
necessary and so yeah I'd rather have
more fewer deeper meaningful
relationships with both friends but also
with my brand
interesting have you identified
that the strategy or the relationship
with the brands has evolved over the
last maybe a couple decades you know
with with different engagements and
different from you know from the
generations the the way that your trust
is changing in our community and what's
been changing in terms of you know brand
strategy on a higher level over these
last few years
yeah I think a couple things have
happened obviously with the technology
with uh the consumers call it
involvement and engagement and ability
to to have voice on the brand
relationship and both of those
accelerating what I call the pace of
both brand creation
and adoption but also brand let's say uh
termination right in terms of like you
know I I can swap out a brand very
easily now with another brand right you
know presents new challenges for those
of us who are brand stewards
um and so I think that's probably one of
the biggest challenges is
um the disposability
of Brands and the creation and the the
so-called the quick creation of new
brands in that type of climate I think
it's even more important not to lose
focus on that one percent right the one
percent that you really need to speak um
to because if you speak to them and you
speak to them better than anybody else
that one percent's voice has influence
over the other 99 but I feel like a lot
of Brands
um lose sight of that and they start
chasing shiny new objects they start
chasing sort of new customer bases
because they are on the you know need
for growth or or they're being
challenged at their Left Flank and their
right flank and they're so worried about
those that they lose focus on where they
are already strong where they already
have a base where they already have
traction and so a lot of times I
challenge Brands I said don't you know
don't always chase the new innovate the
old innovate where you're already strong
innovate where you already have great
customers and and consumers who love you
innovate where you already have supply
chain strength and where you already you
know have a distribution and where you
already have your marketing dollars go
farther than other people instead of
trying to always worry about what's new
and what's coming at you
right now I mean that makes a lot of
sense and um and so final tip for for
young entrepreneurs that are just
starting their journey and regardless if
they're going for a huge for a Big Brand
small brand they're trying to create
trust with their customers what what is
what is an exercise that you would
encourage a young entrepreneur to to do
with themselves with their team as
they're building as they're thinking
about what they're representing in in
their company what what is something
that that you recommend to your friends
and your and your clients to do yeah I
think there's a simple exercise you can
actually do it on a very personal level
with respect to you know yourself and
your career and how you uh show up
against your peers you can obviously do
it with your product services and and
the brand that you're managing no matter
the size of it and it's this you need to
answer this question what's your
signature
one thing that if I pulled three of your
customers okay that's all I just need
three of your customers that they would
say that one would be the same thing
okay they would consistently say the
same thing
and then two it would be something that
is actually truly yours and ownable
versus yeah any competitor could
actually say the same thing so you can
actually have one signature like you you
know if a 99 out of 100 people that have
met you get to know you from a business
perspective said this is the guru of the
20 minute leader okay I mean that is who
you are it's your signature you own it
and you know both the 20 minute the
leader that that part of is embodied in
everything Michael does okay which is
fantastic so whatever it is on a
personal level and then on a
professional level and and and and in
the work that you're doing and the
brands that you manage what is your
signature 10 people if I brought three
people together one would they all say
the same thing okay that's the first
test
would what they say
um not only be the same thing but it
would be something that they actually
thought was meaningful to them and
something they cared about and then
three it's something that none of your
competitors could say if you can pass
those three tests with three of your
customers or three of your friends then
guess what you have something that is
going to stick that's going to last that
you're going to invest against that will
have huge dividends in terms of making
you stand out and making you ownable
amazing soon thank you so much for the
time the energy I learned so much and
this conversation is leading me with the
thoughts and what the more energized to
now think about whatever Brands I get to
work on whatever Brands my friends are
getting to work on and a new lens of
thinking about this idea of being an
iconic brand and creating
um and you know playing the game so
thank you very very much this was so
nice and uh and I and I look forward to
continue keeping in touch and getting
advice from you around around whatever
Brands I get to create so thank you
wonderful Michael thank you
foreign
[Music]